Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Hello and welcome to The Rest Is History. And if you are listening to this the moment that the programme has dropped early on the 1st of November, then you will be listening to it on the night that traditionally has been regarded perhaps more than any other night of the year as especially numinous as especially dangerous we have just celebrated halloween um and the big question is dominic sandbrook yeah how far back does this celebration go oh it must go back to about the 1990s um as far as when people started seeing it in American.
感谢收听《历史其余部分》。想要获取每周独家播客、无广告收听、系列节目抢先体验以及加入我们深受喜爱的聊天社区的会员资格，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。你好，欢迎收听《历史其余部分》。如果你在节目于11月1日一早发布的瞬间就开始收听，那么你听到的这个夜晚，传统上可能比一年中的任何其他夜晚都更被视为具有神圣感，特别危险，我们刚刚庆祝完万圣节，嗯，最大的问题是，多米尼克·桑德布鲁克，是的，这个庆祝活动可以追溯到多久以前？哦，它一定可以追溯到大约20世纪90年代，嗯，就人们开始在美国看到它的时候而言。
I used to be a massive Halloween skeptic. I despised Halloween, absolutely despised it as an American invention. And then of course my, my son who's now nine came along and he loves, he's, you know, Halloween is one of his favorite days of the year and it's obviously,
我曾经是个坚定的万圣节怀疑论者。我鄙视万圣节，绝对鄙视它，认为它是美国发明的产物。然后，当然，我的儿子，他现在九岁了，出生了，他很喜欢，他你知道的，万圣节是他一年中最喜欢的日子之一，很显然，
it's swept all before it, hasn't it? But the interesting question is is this the re-importation back to britain of an originally british and irish um festival or is it pagan festival or so in other words does it is there something in it that takes us back to the mysterious kind of murky world of our pre-Christian ancestors? Or is it the creation of a Walmart executive in deepest middle America? Absolutely. And that's why today's program is going to be on the theme of paganism. I mean, a massive topic. I don't know. Stonehenge, druids, the Occult, Horned Gods, Mother Goddesses, Greek and Roman
它席卷了一切，不是吗？但有趣的问题是，这到底是原本属于英国和爱尔兰的节日向英国的回流，还是它是一个异教节日？换句话说，其中是否有某种东西能把我们带回到我们前基督教祖先那种神秘而又模糊的世界？还是说它是深层美国腹地的一位沃尔玛高管创造的产物？绝对是的。这就是为什么今天的节目将围绕异教主题展开。我的意思是，这是一个巨大的话题。我不知道，巨石阵、德鲁伊、神秘主义、带角的山羊神、大地女神、希腊和罗马
paganism, Snake Gods yeah it's a massive subject it's it's a brilliant subject and I thought it would be fun so we're going to look at Halloween then we'll look at kind of modern paganism and then it would be quite fun to go backwards in time backwards in time interesting backwards in time yes backwards in time to the very beginnings of uh of paganism so if you're here for the druids um just wait we'll get there um we'll get there via wicker and all this other all this other stuff to answer that specific question about halloween and we have one here from tim vasby bernie um who is a friend of the show and i should say a vicar yeah he can't be a halloween fan if he's a vicar, surely.
异教，蛇神，是的，这是一个庞大的主题，这是一个绝妙的主题，我觉得这会很有趣，所以我们要先看看万圣节，然后看看现代异教，接着以倒流的时间来探讨会相当有趣，倒流的时间，有趣，倒流的时间，是的，倒流到呃异教的最开始。所以如果你是冲着德鲁伊来的，呃，稍等一下，我们会讲到那里的，呃，我们会通过柳条人以及所有这些其他的东西来探讨它。为了回答关于万圣节的那个具体问题，我们有一位听众发来的提问，来自蒂姆·瓦斯比·伯尼，他是节目的老朋友，我应该说他是一位牧师，嗯，既然他是牧师，他怎么可能是万圣节迷呢，这肯定不可能。
He says, aren't a lot of these Christians took over pagan myths, ideas, fake, such as in the case of Halloween? Now there is really only one person, I think, to answer that question and to talk about paganism more generally. And that is the great Ronald Hutton, who, because today is a day where we remember the dead, I would like to remember my beloved uncle, David Gregory, who I think in, it must have been 1990 or something, gave me as my Christmas present, a biography of Charles II.
他说，难道很多这些基督教接管的异教神话、想法，都是假的吗，就像万圣节的情况那样？现在，我想真正只有一个人能够回答这个问题，并更广泛地谈论异教。那就是伟大的罗纳德·哈顿，因为今天是缅怀逝者的日子，我想缅怀我敬爱的叔叔大卫·格雷戈里，我想在1990年左右，或者是别的什么时候，他送给我一本查理二世的传记作为圣诞礼物。
Oh, that's a great book. Ronald Hutton, by Ronald Hutton. And Ronald is a great historian of the mid 17th century, his most recent book, The Making of Cromwell, absolutely my history book of the year so far. But I was very surprised, I think in the, again, the late 90s, where I came across a book called The Stations of the Sun, which was about the ritual year in Britain. So it was exactly about these kinds of questions, is Halloween, does it go back to pagan times, Christmas, all that kind of stuff. And then subsequently, again, my uncle gave me what I think is the best named academic text I've ever come across, Witches, Druids, and King Arthur. And Ronald,
哦，那是一本好书。罗纳德·哈顿写的，罗纳德·哈顿。罗纳德是17世纪中期的一位伟大历史学家，他最近的书《克伦威尔的塑造》绝对是我今年迄今为止的历史书首选。但我非常惊讶，我想还是在90年代末，我偶然读到了一本名为《太阳的驿站》的书，这本书是关于英国的仪式化年度节庆的。所以它恰恰探讨了这类问题，万圣节是否可以追溯到异教时期，圣诞节，诸如此类的事情。然后随后，同样是我叔叔送给了我一本我认为是我见过的名字最好的学术著作，《女巫、德鲁伊与亚瑟王》，而罗纳德，
in that book, you finished it with a kind of incredible essay about the challenge of writing about paganism, in which you revealed something that I hadn't realised until that point, which was that you were actually brought up as a pagan. Is that right? Yes, in a very hazy kind of way, meaning that I was brought up in a household which depended on two sources of spirituality. The first was the Greek and Roman classics, the basis of an English education in the last 200 years. And the second was a love of the countryside, specifically the English countryside.
在那本书中，你以一篇精彩绝伦的文章作为结尾，探讨了书写异教所面临的挑战，并在其中透露了一件我在此之前没有意识到事情，那就是你实际上是作为一个异教徒被抚养长大的。是这样吗？是的，以一种非常模糊的方式，意思是我在一个依赖两种精神源泉的家庭中长大。第一种是希腊和罗马经典，这是过去两00年来英国教育的基础；第二种是对乡村的热爱，特别是英国乡村。
And the two were put together in a very Victorian Edwardian manner, a very wind in the willows manner to give an idea of the countryside as basically a sacred place full of spirits and populated by romping Greek and Roman deities and that really is a huge literature from the English in particular from the late 19th early 20th century to support this and I grew up on that and absorbed it thoroughly and it did mean that when I encountered
这两者以一种非常维多利亚和爱德华时期的、非常《柳林风声》的方式结合在一起，将乡村描绘成一个基本上神圣的地方，里面充满了精灵，并居住着嬉戏的希腊和罗马神祇，对于英国人来说，特别是从19世纪末到20世纪初，确实有大量的文学作品来支持这一点，我就是在这种环境中长大的，并且彻底吸收了它，这确实意味着当我遇到
modern forms of paganism in my adolescence, they seemed to be natural outgrowths from this. And I think historically, that's exactly what they were. So I was quite disposed to be friendly to them. And is that what prompted your kind of academic interest in the subject? Yes, exactly. But all my academic interests are outgrowths from things that fascinated me between the age of 12 and 15. That's true. Middle age should be a revenge lifestyle in which you actually get to do everything you really wanted to do as an early adolescent. So what about this question that Tom kicked off with then, before we get into the issue of paganism more broadly? Halloween. So Halloween, is there any continuity really
青春期时遇到现代形式的异教，它们似乎是这种背景的自然延伸。我认为从历史上看，它们也确实如此。所以我相当乐意对它们保持友好。这就是激发你对这个学科的学术兴趣的原因吗？是的，完全是。但我所有的学术兴趣都是从12岁到15岁之间让我着迷的事物中衍生出来的。确实如此。中年应该是一种复仇式的生活方式，让你真正能够去做你在青春期早期时极其渴望做的所有事情。那么，在深入探讨更广泛的异教问题之前，汤姆提出的这个关于万圣节的问题又如何呢？万圣节，那么万圣节，到底有没有任何连贯性
between this and older festivals? Because the festival is Samhain. Samhain. Samhain, Tom. Which is, just before we started, I asked you how you pronounce it. Because it's actually, in English, it looks like Samhain,
在这个节日和更古老的节日之间？因为这个节日是萨温节。萨温节。萨温节，汤姆。就在我们开始之前，我问过你该怎么发音。因为在英语里，它看起来像萨温，
which kind of sounds like a football manager or something kind of big sam um so so is there a link between sawin and halloween you bet there is uh first sawin is just the gaelic name for a festival found right across ancient Northern Europe to mark the division between autumn and winter. It's known to the Welsh, who are after all the native speakers of the original Britain, as Nose Galan, Winter's Eve, which is often forgotten now, but it's really beautiful. And as all hallows to medieval Christians. It's always had two aspects. One is that it's the time when there's
听起来有点像某个足球经理或者诸如此类的大人物“萨姆”，所以，萨温节和万圣节之间有联系吗？当然有！首先，“萨温”只是盖尔语中一个遍布古代北欧的节日的名称，用来标志秋季和冬季的分界线。威尔士人（他们毕竟是古代不列颠土著语言的使用者）称其为“诺斯加兰”（Nose Galan），即冬夜，现在这经常被遗忘，但它真的很美；而中世纪的基督徒则称其为“诸圣节”。它一直有两个方面。一方面，这是一年中
most plenty around, the harvest is in, the beer's been brewed, the cheese has been made, and so you actually have materials for a feast. And you slaughter the animals you can't feed through the winter, so it's one of the few times of the year when ordinary people can eat meat in abundance doesn't be to say that november is blood month yes blood month because of the slaughter no no more sinister reason but also it's on the verge of the most loathsome of all the seasons in the northern hemisphere it's a time when even if things are good you're going to suffer from claustrophobia boredom vermin cold mud interior dirt and tv specials and in bad ears and traditional societies from famine epidemic disease and hypothermia lethal hypotherothermia. So it's really scary. So the shiver of the risk of
物产最丰饶的时候，收获已经完成，啤酒已经酿好，奶酪已经做好，所以你实际上拥有了举行盛宴的物质条件。而且你要屠宰那些无法度过冬天的动物，所以这是一年中普通人能够大口吃肉的少数几个时期之一。这并不是说十一月是血月，是的，因为屠宰而被称为血月，没有其他更阴险的原因。但这也是北欧半月最令人厌恶的季节的边缘，这是一个即使一切顺利，你也要遭受幽闭恐惧症、无聊、害虫、寒冷、泥泞、室内污垢和电视特别节目折磨的时期；而在糟糕的年份里，传统社会的民众还要遭受饥荒、瘟疫、疾病和低体温症的折磨，致命的低体温症。所以这真的很可怕。因此，死亡风险的战栗
death and the spirits of the dark hangs over this crucial juncture of the year. And that combination of the fun and the feasting and the merrymaking and the shiver of terror runs through Halloween now. But also there's a Christian dimension that building on this darkening of the year, around about a thousand years after the time of Christ, the Western Christian churches decided to have a feast there for all saints, all the saints they couldn't fit into other days of the year, especially martyrs. And they coupled this with a remembering of the dead, largely because of the new medieval idea around that time that most people don't go straight to heaven or hell, but have their sins burned away in a purifying granny in purgatory, and that would soothe their pain and get some time knocked off their sentence. It's the idea that it's a festival of the dead.
和黑暗幽灵的阴影笼罩着一年中的这个关键转折点。娱乐、盛宴、欢庆以及恐惧的战栗，这种结合贯穿了如今的万圣节。但同时，它也有一个基督教的维度，即在建立在一年逐渐变黑的基础上，大约在基督诞生一千年后，西方基督教会决定在那里设立一个节日，纪念所有的圣灵，也就是那些无法塞进一年中其他日期的圣灵，尤其是殉道者。他们将此与缅怀逝者结合起来，这在很大程度上是因为当时新的中世纪观念，即大多数人不会直接去天堂或地狱，而是在炼狱里由一位净化的“老奶奶”烧掉他们的罪孽，这会减轻他们的痛苦，并为他们的刑期减刑。这就是它作为亡灵节的理念。
Is that specifically a Christian idea? Or is that one that we can trace back? It is, yes. Yeah. As far as we can reconstruct from older texts and general North European folklore. Before round about 1000 AD CE, Halloween wasn't really about the dead so much as about the fear of your own death, the fear of dying, the fear of the lethal season to come. So that's the winter element predominantly. That's right. That's exactly it. But winter was a killer until modern times, so that this is heavy stuff.
这专门是一个基督教的概念吗？还是我们可以追溯到更早的渊源？是的，确实如此。嗯。据我们从更古老的文本和北欧的普遍民间传说中所能重建的来看。在大约公元1000年之前，万圣节其实并不是关于死者的，而是关于对自身死亡的恐惧，对死去的恐惧，对即将到来的致命季节的恐惧。所以这主要是冬季的元素。没错。完全是这样。但在现代之前，冬天是个杀手，所以这可不是闹着玩的。
And it was the Christian church that introduced the idea of thinking about those who are already dead and caring for them and praying for them. And in Catholic countries, that goes on to the present. reason why Halloween is so big in America is the Irish, who remained majority Catholic, took it over with them big time to America when they emigrated there in their millions, and gave it to the Americans who commercialised it in the 20th century, and then sold it back to us in a classic colonial relation. So it's a kind of Catholic revenge on Protestant England for getting rid of it? Not really. It's just the fact there are certain things that Protestantism, like other religions, cannot reach. Yes, yes. And I suppose, I mean, I suppose this idea of this time of year as a time of dread
正是基督教教会引入了缅怀那些已经逝去的人、关爱他们并为他们祈祷的想法。在天主教国家，这种传统一直延续至今。万圣节在美国如此盛行的一个原因，是那些仍然保持天主教多数派的爱尔兰人，在他们成百上千万人移民到美国时，把这个节日大举带到了美国，并把它交给了在20世纪将其商业化的美国人，然后又以一种经典的殖民关系把它卖回给我们。所以这有点像天主教对摆脱了它的新教英国的一种报复？倒也不是。这只是因为有些事情，新教就像其他宗教一样，是无法触及的。是的，是的。我想，我的意思是，我想把一年中的这个时候视为充满恐惧的时刻的想法，
has kind of been revived by all the anxiety around COVID and the sense that winter is going to be a more dangerous time. Perhaps, you know, first time in a fair while, people are nervous of the winter in a way that they perhaps kind of gives us a very, very faint echo of how it used to be. Oh, absolutely. So for the last few years, even before the coronavirus struck, we've had the Vistra of the National Health preparing to collapse every winter. It's just serious stuff if you're on a stretcher. So winter is starting to look like a really scary big deal. And summer, like this brief interlude of happiness between two bouts of misery for the first time in over 100 years.
这种想法在某种程度上被围绕新冠肺炎的所有焦虑感以及冬天将成为一个更危险时期的感觉给复活了。也许，你知道的，这是相当长一段时间以来的第一次，人们对冬天感到紧张，这种方式也许给了我们一个非常非常微弱的回响，让人想起过去的日子是怎么样的。哦，绝对是这样的。因此，在过去几年里，甚至在冠状病毒爆发之前，我们每年冬天都要面对国家医疗服务体系准备崩溃的幽灵。如果你躺在担架上，这可真不是闹着玩的。所以冬天开始看起来像是一个真正可怕的大事件。而夏天，在100多年来第一次成为两次苦难之间短暂的幸福插曲。
Can I just ask a question about the continuity? So when the great reformation, the great revolution happens in the 16th century, and the practice of praying for the dead is effectively outlawed, it's removed from the calendar. Are people, do you think, still doing it surreptitiously? Does it survive in kind of folk memory, do you think? or does it genuinely just disappear from England? It survives in folk memory for quite a while for example for a couple of generations after the reformation in Lancashire farming families would go out on Halloween night and they would ignite straw and hold it up on pitchforks and they'd be able to pray for the dead as long as the straw was burning because they couldn't do it in church anymore.
我能问一个关于延续性的问题吗？那么，当伟大的宗教改革、伟大的革命在16世纪发生时，为死者祈祷的做法实际上被取名违法了，它被从日历中删除了。你认为人们是否仍然在秘密地这样做？你认为它是否以某种民间记忆的形式生存下来？还是说它真的就从英格兰消失了？它在民间记忆中存活了一段时间，例如，在宗教改革后的好几代人里，兰开夏郡的农耕家庭会在万圣节之夜外出，他们会点燃稻草并用草叉高高举起，只要稻草还在燃烧，他们就能为死者祈祷，因为他们不能再去教堂里这样做了。
But generally, observance of Halloween died out in England and lowland Scotland for about 300 years, a couple of generations after the Reformation, leaving just this uneasy feeling about it as something when people did something you're not supposed to do anymore. But also the beginning of winter, Friesland. So that idea that I guess that in Protestant England, that celebrating this stuff is kind of papist. I mean, is that the kind of thing that essentially is underlying The Wicker Man? I mean, The Wicker Man is about a kind of a pagan tradition going on. But actually, I mean, the policeman who ends up being burnt, spoiler alert, he's a kind of very devout Protestant, isn't he? I mean, is there a sense in which it's Protestant anxieties about Catholic holdovers that then inform how in ghost stories and horror stories and so on, paganism is seen? A bit. Protestants simply have more problems with paganism than Catholics or even more problems,
但总的来说，万圣节在英格兰和苏格兰低地的庆祝活动在宗教改革后持续了几代人、大约300年的时间，之后便消亡了，只留下这种不安的感觉：人们在做一件你不再应该做的事。但这也是冬天的开始，弗里斯兰。所以我想那种在新教英格兰庆祝这些东西是“教皇党”派头的想法。我的意思是，这基本上就是潜藏在《异教徒》（The Wicker Man）背后的那种东西吗？我的意思是，《异教徒》讲述的是一个正在进行的异教传统。但实际上，我的意思是，那个最终被烧死的警察，剧透预警，他其实是一个非常虔诚的新教徒，不是吗？我的意思是，新教徒对天主教遗留事物的焦虑，是否在某种程度上构成了鬼故事、恐怖故事等作品中异教观的背景？有一点。新教徒对异教的问题比天主教徒更多，甚至有更多的问题，
because both pagans and Catholics are heavy on religious ritual and Protestants are not. So to a lot of particularly evangelical extreme Protestants, ritual in itself is something suspect. But the wicker man motif actually comes from something more modern and still pretty deep lodged. It appears in the 1890s, which is when for the first time, the English start to realise that a modern pagan revival might be taking place in their midst, the kind of paganism among which I grew up, in fact. And so there is a reaction among both devout Christians and people who aren't Christians anymore, but just don't want any more religion around, especially revived religion. And so this motif creeps into literature of the outsider going to a respectable looking rural British community
因为异教徒和天主教徒都很注重宗教仪式，而新教徒则不然。因此，对许多尤其是福音派的极端新教徒来说，仪式本身就是一件可疑的事情。但“稻草人”的主题实际上源于更现代且依然根深蒂固的事物。它出现在19世纪90年代，当时英国人第一次开始意识到，现代异教的复兴可能正在他们身边发生，事实上，这也是我成长过程中的那种异教。因此，虔诚的基督徒和那些不再是基督徒、只是不希望周围再有宗教（尤其是复兴的宗教）的人之间产生了反应。于是，这个主题潜入了文学作品中，讲述一个外地人来到一个看似体面的英国乡村社区，
and finding out that the locals are still secretly pagans or have gone back to being pagans. And it almost always ends in tears because paganism reveals itself to be a bloodthirsty, terrifying religion. And sometimes there's a happy ending. John Buchan, the author of The 39 Steps and all those great thrillers, is very big on this. He wrote about it three times.
却发现当地人仍然秘密地信奉异教，或者已经回归异教。而且这几乎总是以悲剧收场，因为异教最终显露出它是一个嗜血、可怕的宗教。有时也会有圆满的结局。约翰·巴肯（John Buchan），《三十九级台阶》及所有这些伟大惊悚小说的作者，非常热衷于此。他曾三次写到这个主题。
But always there's a strapping Christian hero who obviously went to a very good school who comes along and messes everything up for the pagans. So, Ronald, can I ask a question? I mean, this very nicely takes us to that point at the late 19th, early 20th century when paganism is clearly, well, it's either being revived or it's being invented, depending on your sort of historical perspective. So before we talk about
但总会有一个身材魁梧、显然读过名校的基督教英雄出现，把异教徒的一切都搞砸。所以，罗纳德，我可以问个问题吗？我的意思是，这非常巧妙地把我们带到了19世纪末20世纪初的那个时间点，当时异教显然——嗯，要么正在复兴，要么正在被发明，这取决于你的某种历史视角。所以在我们讨论
that, what is it about that moment? Is it to do with the anxieties of an urban industrial society? Is it to do with modernism, the First World War? What is it about that time that gives people this thirst for, you know, horned gods and mother goddesses and this sort of stuff? You're good, Dominic. You've managed to wrap most of it within a minute. It is about the anxieties. You can come again.
这一点之前，那个时期的特点是什么？它是否与城市工业社会的焦虑有关？它是否与现代主义、第一次世界大战有关？那个时代究竟有什么，让人们对（你知道的）带角的山羊神、大地女神以及诸如此类的事物产生了渴望？你很厉害，多米尼克。你在不到一分钟的时间里把大部分内容都概括进去了。它确实与焦虑有关。你还可以再来。
It is about the anxieties of urbanising, industrialising society, which produce this new sense of the country, something sacred, something alien, something endangered, for which Christianity doesn't really provide an adequate literature, or as ancient paganism does, with its sense of a sacred nature. But also it's the unravellling of mainstream British Christianity. We are turning into a post-Christian multi-faith society for the first time. We're getting large numbers of Jewish refugees settling among us. You have ideas coming in from the East for the first time on a large scale, forms of Buddhism and Hinduism that Westerners are finding attractive.
它确实与城市化、工业化社会的焦虑有关，这产生了一种对乡村的新感觉——一种神圣的、陌生的、处于危险之中的事物，基督教并没有真正为之提供充足的文学表达，而古代异教却做到了，它带有对神圣自然的感觉。但这也是主流英国基督教的解体。我们正在首次变成一个后基督教的多元信仰社会。我们迎来了大批犹太难民在我们中间定居。东方思想历史上第一次大规模流入，西方人开始发现佛教和印度教的各种形式很有吸引力。
So there is this sense of a Christian consensus breaking down. And there's also a kind of middle class, upper class fear of the newly empowered swarming masses of the huge new urban working class with its trade unions and its music halls, and the sense that it might just shake off the middle class rather like a horse shaking off flies in George Orwell's image. And also that of this vast colonial empire with these huge numbers of subject ethnically different populations and this tiny precarious elite of Europeans governing them. So there's an enormous whirlpool of anxieties there with paganism bobbing around in it.
因此，人们感觉到基督教的共识正在崩溃。此外，中产阶级和上层阶级对新获得力量、蜂拥而至的庞大城市新工人阶级（及其工会和音乐厅）感到恐惧，觉得他们可能会像乔治·奥威尔笔下的马甩掉苍蝇一样，把中产阶级甩掉。还有那个庞大的殖民帝国，拥有数量庞大、种族不同的臣民人口，而统治他们的却是一小群岌岌可危的欧洲精英。因此，那里有一个巨大的焦虑漩涡，而异教就在其中沉浮。
And is paganism satisfying those anxieties or is it generating them? Well, it has a double bonus. If you're part of the worried mainstream, then it provides a good punch bag. You can take out your anxieties upon it by writing novels like those of John Buchan. On the other hand, if you've been brought up on cold baths and preachers, the idea of an ancient religion with revered old, rather beautiful text and a tremendous art that basically tells you it's OK to roll up the grass, get naked, enjoy sex and have fun. Which Kenneth Graham's wife did, didn't she? And Kenneth Graham on their kind of wedding morning, they rolled around in dew. And he famously wrote in Wind in the Willows, wrote a vision of Pan, who becomes, I guess, a kind of emblem of that movement. Yeah, we're going a bit too far with the Grahams and their wedding day, to which I admit fault because I built them up in a book. Oh, he was too timid.
那么异教是在缓解这些焦虑还是在产生焦虑呢？嗯，它有着双重好处。如果你是忧心忡忡的主流群体的一员，那么它提供了一个很好的出气筒。你可以通过写像约翰·巴肯那样的小说，把你的焦虑发泄在它上面。另一方面，如果你从小受冷水澡和传教士的教育，一个拥有受人尊敬的古老、相当美丽文本和宏大艺术的古代宗教的想法，基本上会告诉你：在草地上打滚、光着身子、享受性爱和尽情狂欢是没有问题的。肯尼斯·格雷厄姆的妻子就是这样做的，对吧？肯尼斯·格雷厄姆在他们举行婚礼的早晨，他们在露珠里打滚。他曾在《柳林风声》中出名地写道，描绘了潘神的愿景，我猜潘神后来成为了那种运动的某种象征。是的，我们在格雷厄姆夫妇和他们的婚礼上扯得有点远了，我承认这是我的错，因为我在一本书里把他们写得很丰满。哦，他太胆小了。
He was pagan in his instincts, but didn't want to upset the family. It was she, his wife, who really rebelled, didn't want a church wedding, refused to wear a ring, refused to wear a white dress. And on their wedding day, it was she who went out and rolled in her wedding dress in the dune and put a crown of flowers in her head to establish her identity as a pagan. And she turned up looking like a thundercloud in church in this wrinkled, sodden floral dress with this large bunch of lilting flowers in her head. And the marriage went downhill from there. But pan in the wind and the willows is really, really important. For a start, he shouldn't be there. He's not part of the story. And he disrupts the tone, which has been ironic, mostly, here the two, about the misadventures
他的本能是异教徒，但又不想惹恼家人。真正叛逆的是他的妻子，她不想要传统的教堂婚礼，拒绝戴戒指，拒绝穿白纱。在他们的婚礼那天，是她走了出去，穿着婚纱在沙丘里打滚，头上戴着一顶花冠，以此确立她作为异教徒的身份。当她走进教堂时，看起来就像一朵雷雨云，穿着这件满是褶皱、湿漉漉的花朵长裙，头上顶着一大束摇曳的花朵。从那以后，他们的婚姻就走下坡路了。但《柳林风声》中的潘神真的非常非常重要。首先，他不应该出现在那里。他不是故事的一部分。而且他打破了基调，这种基调在此之前基本上带有讽刺意味，讲述的是
of Mr. Toad, you know, a classic parable of nouveau riche bourgeois anxiety about what the working class stoats and weasels are going to do to you. And suddenly, there is this explosive chapter out of nowhere with this epiphany of a pagan god, realised in the most intense religious terms. And Graham can only get away with this, because he's ostensibly writing about animals, to whom Pan can be a god, as Jesus can be to us. But since the animals behave like middle-class Victorian humans, it's deeply ambivalent. Can I ask about another book of the late Victorian period, a book that I think you know an awful lot about? So I don't know if I'm pronouncing it right, but it's Aradia, or Aradia, I don't know which, by Charles Godfrey Leland. Now, you talked about the discovering of texts
托德先生的倒霉经历，你知道的，这是关于新贵资产阶级对工人阶级的白鼬和黄鼠狼会对你做什么的焦虑的经典寓言。突然之间，毫无征兆地出现了这个充满爆发力的章节，伴随着异教神明显现的顿悟，以最强烈的宗教术语展现出来。格雷厄姆之所以能蒙混过关，是因为他表面上写的是动物，潘神对动物而言可以是神，就像耶稣对我们一样。但既然这些动物的行为举止像中产阶级维多利亚时代的人类，这就变得极其矛盾了。我可以问一本关于维多利亚时代晚期的另一本书吗？一本我想你非常了解的书。所以，我不知道我发音是否正确，但它是查尔斯·戈弗雷·莱兰（Charles Godfrey Leland）写的《阿拉迪娅》（Aradia），或者叫阿拉迪娅，我不知道具体是哪个。现在，你谈到了发现
underlying paganism, and this is in some ways, I mean, it's subtitled The Gospel of the Witches. And this is a book, I think, am I right in thinking you spoke about this when you were 20 or so in a public debate defending it and then changed your views? So this is a book that pretends to, or claims to be, rather, pretends is a loaded word, it claims to be the account of a surviving witch tradition in Tuscany and that this became a foundational text. Well, this did become a foundational text for modern paganism, didn't it? It certainly did. It deserves to be. It's beautifully written.
异教背后的文本，从某些方面来看，我的意思是，它的副标题是《女巫福音》。这是一本书，我想我没记错的话，你在20岁左右的一次公开辩论中曾谈到过这本书，当时你还在为它辩护，后来却改变了看法？所以这是一本书，它假装，或者说声称自己是——“假装”这个词带有一种倾向性——它声称自己是托斯卡纳幸存女巫传统的记录，并成为了现代异教的奠基文本。嗯，这确实成为了现代异教的奠基文本，不是吗？确实如此。它当之无愧。它写得太美了。
I was 19 and drunk on it, and I went up against Norman Cone, who was a great scholar of that period. And he wiped the floor with me. He did so very courteously. But it was the first time that I had an inkling that I might actually be wrong about this book. And indeed, I probably was. The late 19th century is the great age of folklore collecting all over Europe, in which urban intellectuals are going into the countryside and collecting stories and customs from ordinary rural people in the belief that they are living fossils of ancient belief and ritual. And one of
我当时19岁，为之如痴如醉，我去和诺曼·科恩（Norman Cone）辩论，他是一位那个时期的伟大学者。他把我打得落花流水。他做得非常有礼貌。但那是第一次，我隐约觉得我对这本书的看法可能是错的。事实上，我也确实错了。19世纪末是整个欧洲收集民间传说的伟大时代，城市知识分子深入乡村，从普通农村民众那里收集故事和习俗，坚信他们是古代信仰和仪式的活化石。而其中
these is Charles Godfrey Leland, an American left-wing adventurer, a great radical, and a believer in revolution, who goes to live in Italy for a long time. And he comes out with a lot of Italian folklore, which everybody reckons is genuine, and a radia, which is supposed to be a gospel of a pagan witch cult. Now, the idea that a pagan witch cult had been there was something raised earlier in the 19th century. The idea that the people persecuted as witches in the notorious witch trials of late medieval early modern Europe where practitioners of a surviving pagan religion had been suggested from the 1820s onwards as one solution to the problem of why there were witch trials, why rational Europeans should do something so dreadful and stupid
的一位就是查尔斯·戈弗雷·莱兰，一个美国左翼冒险家、伟大的激进分子和革命信仰者，他在意大利住了很长一段时间。他整理出了大量的意大利民间传说，大家都认为那是真的，还有《阿拉迪娅》，据称这是一部异教女巫教派的福音书。现在，中世纪异教女巫教派曾经存在的观点，在19世纪初就已经被提出了。那种认为在中世纪晚期、近代早期欧洲臭名昭著的女巫审判中被当成女巫迫害的人，实际上是幸存的异教宗教的实践者的观点，从1820年代开始就被提出，作为解释为什么会有女巫审判这一问题的一种解决方案——为什么理性的欧洲人会做出如此可怕和愚蠢的事情，
as putting people to death for presumed satanic conspiracies. And what Leland did was produce what he thought was or claimed was the actual gospel of this pagan witch cult. Ever since then, A, no historian of 19th century Italy has come across any other evidence of such a cult. B, it's easy to see where the image in the book is coming from. It's coming from the portraits of the witch trials. The same cast of characters is there, the same motifs. And C, analysis of the manuscript shows that he did have a collector, a local, who came back with the stuff, but there's no proof she produced the manuscript. And it doesn't seem originally to itself have been composed by somebody who spoke Italian fluently or knew it. So the whole thing looks decidedly fishy. The good thing about it is, to go back to my original
把人们以假定的撒旦阴谋为由处以死刑。而莱兰所做的是，制作了他认为或声称是这个异教女巫教派的真正福音书。从那以后，A，没有一位19世纪意大利的历史学家发现过任何此类教派的其他证据；B，很容易看出书中图像的来源，它来自女巫审判的肖像画，其中的人物阵容是一样的，母题也是一样的；C，对手稿的分析表明，他确实有一个当地的收集者带回了这些材料，但没有证据证明是她制作了这份手稿，而且它最初似乎也不是由一个能流利说意大利语或了解意大利语的人创作的。所以整件事情看起来明显疑点重重。不过它的好处是——回到我最初的
statement, it is beautifully written and quite inspiring for those who want a rebel, counter-cultural witch religion meeting out in the woods. Right. And I remember in the 1970s, I think it was the Reader's Digest Guide to Folklore. It kind of had an image of a horned man on the front, and it had fabulous illustrations. And in that, there was the very exciting thesis that William Rufus, who is shot in the New Forest, that this had been part of a witch cult and that he'd offered himself up as a living sacrifice. That seems very implausible, Tom.
陈述——它写得非常优美，对于那些想要寻找一个在树林里集会的、叛逆的反文化女巫宗教的人来说，相当具有启发性。对的。我记得在20世纪70年代，好像是《读者文摘》的民间传说指南吧。它的封面上有一种带角的男性形象，里面有绝妙的插图。在那本书里，有一个非常令人兴奋的论点：威廉·鲁弗斯（William Rufus，即威廉二世），他在新森林中被射杀，这其实是女巫教派的一部分，他把自己作为活人祭品献了出去。这听起来很不合理，汤姆。
Well, we have the world expert on this. That's not true, is it? That didn't happen. I'm not a world expert on this. I don't think anybody should be a world expert on anything. But the hypothesis you're stating was that of a very remarkable person from the early 20th century, a very good Egyptologist called Margaret Murray, who, to put it bluntly, went on holiday, wrote books about the history of witchcraft, which were highly imaginative, highly speculative, and very popular. And it was she who took the 19th century idea that the people who had been prosecuted for witchcraft, allegedly,
嗯，我们这里有这方面的世界级专家。这不是真的，对吧？那没有发生。我不是这方面的世界级专家。我不认为任何人应该成为任何事物的世界级专家。但你刚才陈述的假设是20世纪初一个非常了不起的人提出的，她是一位非常优秀的埃及学家，名叫玛格丽特·默里（Margaret Murray）。直白地说，她去度假，写了一些关于巫术历史的书，这些书极具想象力、高度投机性而且非常受欢迎。正是她采纳了19世纪的观点，即那些被指控犯有巫术罪行的人，
had been surviving pagans, and filled it out with quotations from original sources from the period. Experts now reject the hypothesis, but she helped give birth to many of the defining strands of modern paganism. Because increasingly, she came to like the theoretical religion that she'd helped define as a boisterous, fun-loving, nature-loving, radical, popular religion. And as such, it had a great appeal to countercultures in the mid-20th century, including that which I embraced as a teenager. Do you think the fact that she was an Egyptologist also influenced it? No, not terribly, except that she was used to dealing with ancient paganism. What really influenced her view was that she was a lover of folklore. And indeed, she lived to be over 100. She was an amazing lady. She became present to the Folklore Society. And folklorists remember been looking for surviving paganism in the
是幸存的异教徒，并用那个时期原始文献的引用来充实这一观点。专家们现在拒绝接受这一假设，但她确实帮助孕育了现代异教的许多决定性流派。因为她越来越倾向于将她帮助定义的那个理论上的宗教视为一个喧闹的、热爱快乐的、热爱自然的、激进的、大众的宗教。正因如此，它对20世纪中期的反文化运动产生了巨大的吸引力，包括我青少年时期所拥抱的那种反文化运动。你认为她是埃及学家这一事实也对此产生了影响吗？不，没有太大的影响，除非是因为她习惯了处理古代异教。真正影响她的观点的是，她是一个民间传说爱好者。事实上，她活到了100多岁。她是一个了不起的女士。她成为了民间传说协会的主席。在她的时代，民俗学者们已经
countryside for around 100 years by her time. And she just pepped up this picture of the pagan countryside. Can I ask a question? You talked about Leland being left-wing and revolutionary. And when you talk about that counterculture, that sort of early to mid-20th century counterculture, it sounds very reminiscent of George Orwell's famously disparaging lines about the kind of people who he deplores that are attracted to socialism. So he says they're fruit juice drinkers and nudists and sex maniacs and pacifists, and we need to get rid of them if the left is to triumph in Britain. Is there a kind of left-wing dimension to the sort of corporate, increasingly sort of homogenous world of early 20th century Britain? notably left-wing, looking for a socialist utopia using the songs and dances of the common people, or they're notably right-wing, and the right-wing theme is initially dominant in the appearance of modern paganism. It's a wish for an idealized countryside in which everything, including the trees, know their place, but in which there is a
在乡村寻找幸存的异教大约100年了。她只是给这幅异教乡村的画面增添了活力。我可以问一个问题吗？你之前谈到莱兰是左翼的、革命的。当你谈到那种反文化运动，即20世纪初到中期的反文化运动时，这听起来非常让人想起乔治·奥威尔那句著名的贬低之词，他痛斥那些被社会主义吸引的人。他说他们是果汁饮用者、天体主义者、性狂热分子和和平主义者，如果左翼要在英国取得胜利，我们需要摆脱这群人。在20世纪初英国那种企业化、日益同质化的世界里，是否存在某种左翼维度？显著的左翼色彩，利用普通民众的歌曲和舞蹈来寻找社会主义乌托邦；或者它们明显是右翼的，而右翼的主题在现代异教的出现中最初占据主导地位。它是一种对理想化乡村的渴望，在那里一切（包括树木）都各安其位，但其中又有一种
libertarian streak because the common people can still have their fun. Merry England, after all, is very much a conservative idea in the 19th, early 20th centuries, in which the Lord lives in his castle and everybody else dances around the napole and has a good frisky time at midsummer and is happy uh and you're free of all the angst of of revolution and socialism could you if you were doing a sort of family tree and i know this is a huge stretch is it is it a sort of cousin of or is it related distantly to kind of the kind of world of pre-Raphaelitism and William Morris and that sort of thing, do you think? Yeah, it is related, and not too distantly, to all that. So paganism, the barometer of the interest in reviving paganism, swings back and forth between radical
自由主义的特质，因为普通民众仍然可以享受他们的乐趣。毕竟，“欢乐英国”在19世纪和20世纪初是一个非常保守的概念，领主住在城堡里，其他所有人在五朔节柱周围跳舞，在仲夏夜过得快活并感到快乐，而且你摆脱了革命和社会主义的所有痛苦。如果你要做一个家谱——我知道这跨度太大了——它算不算是拉斐尔前派、威廉·莫里斯那种世界的表亲，或者与之有遥远的联系，你觉得呢？是的，它与这一切都有关，而且关系并不太遥远。因此，异教（即对复兴异教的兴趣的晴雨表）从19世纪开始——我这里说的是字面意义上的19世纪初——一直在激进
right and radical left from the 1800s, I'm speaking literally here, the beginning of the 19th century, onwards. And the first people to start celebrating bringing back paganism are the romantic poets. I mean, most of them. You said Keats and everyone. Yeah, Keats, Shelley, Wordsworth, especially Keats and Shelley, who were really, really big at this and actually worshipped pagan deities 100 years before Kenneth Graham met Pan beside the Thames, you get Shelley hanging up a garland to Pan in the woods and building an altar to him. There's that wonderful sonnet by Wordsworth about wishing he could see Triton and belong to a creed at war or whatever it is,
右翼和激进左翼之间摇摆不定。而第一批开始庆祝带回异教的人是浪漫主义诗人。我的意思是，他们中的大多数。你提到了济慈和其他所有人。是的，济慈、雪莱、华兹华斯，尤其是济慈和雪莱，他们在这方面非常投入，在肯尼斯·格雷厄姆在泰晤士河畔遇到潘神之前100年，他们就已经在崇拜异教神祇了。你会看到雪莱在树林里为潘神挂上花环，并为他建造祭坛。华兹华斯还有那首美妙的十四行诗，讲述他希望能看到特里顿，并属于一个处于战争状态的信条，或者诸如此类的内容，
that the world is too much with him and i guess that must be a huge inspiration it is but wordsworth's as you've just said and that stands distinctly iffy about yes yes it sounds great but i i can't quite go there i've got to keep my boots my frock coat on but but keats just gushes love of paganism and also weariness with Christianity. And so does the arch rebel Shelley. Yeah, I think I think we should take a break here because you said that you needed coffee. So I think you should go and get a coffee. And when we come back, I think that could we look at the question that's kind of been hanging over this, which is, is this revival of paganism in the 20th century, is it drawing on ancient traditions that go back all the way to pre-Christian world or not? And if
即世界对他而言过于沉重了，我猜这一定是一个巨大的灵感来源。确实是的，但就像你刚才说的华兹华斯的态度，对它明显持保留态度——是的，是的，听起来很棒，但我不能完全走到那一步，我还得穿着我的靴子、大衣。不过济慈对异教充满了热爱，对基督教也感到厌倦。总反叛者雪莱也是如此。是的，我想我们应该在这里休息一下，因为你说你需要咖啡。所以我觉得你应该去喝杯咖啡。当我们回来时，我想我们能不能看看一直悬而未决的问题，即：20世纪异教的复兴，究竟是在汲取追溯到前基督教世界的古代传统，还是并非如此？如果
not, then where does it come from? And what's been the story of its evolution over the 20th century? So we will be back in a few minutes. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip
不是，那它来自哪里？它在20世纪的演变历程又是怎样的？所以我们几分钟后回来。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们共同主持《娱乐的其余部分》，这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论、一丝娱乐圈八卦，
and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad free listening bonus episodes
在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听、独家播客
and early access to live tickets head to therestisentertainment.com that's therestistertainment.com. That's TheRestIsEntertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. Now, if you listen to our recent podcasts, you will know that although we are as critical of self-promotion and sponsorship deals as anybody,
以及抢先购买现场演出门票的机会，请访问 therestisentertainment.com，网址是 therestisentertainment.com。那就是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史其余部分》。现在，如果你听了我们最近的播客，你就会知道，尽管我们和任何人一样对自我宣传和赞助协议持批评态度，
we happen to be sponsored by an excellent online magazine aren't we tom we are for which both of us have written uh and um the name of that magazine is unheard it's online unheard.com uh and very germainly for our subject today um it has included susanna lipscomb who was um she's got an essay up there right now she did a feature for us on witchcraft and she's got one on why are women becoming witches which actually quotes from Ronald the great Ronald Hutton so it all connects and basically if you're listening to this podcast you can get a special deal with unheard you go to unheard.com slash rest and you get three months free membership so you don't have to pay anything and you can cancel it at any
但我们碰巧得到了一家极棒的在线杂志的赞助，对吧，汤姆？是的，我们是的，我们两人都为它撰过稿，呃，那家杂志的名字叫 UnHerd，网址是 unheard.com，对于我们今天的话题来说非常切题，呃，它刊登了苏珊娜·利普斯科姆（Susanna Lipscomb）的文章，她目前在那上面有一篇随笔，她为我们做了一个关于巫术的专题，其中有一篇关于“为什么女性正在成为女巫”的文章，文中实际上引用了罗纳德——伟大的罗纳德·哈顿的话，所以这一切都串联起来了。基本上，如果你在听这个播客，你就可以通过 UnHerd 获得一个特别优惠，你访问 unheard.com/rest，就可以获得三个月的免费会员资格，所以你不需要支付任何费用，而且你可以随时取消
time and you know the rubric. It's a sensational bargain. Sensational bargain. You can read lots of Tom Holland stuff and it's great. So go to UnHerd, subscribe. Your life will be all the better for it. Now, back to the show. Ronald, we have a question here,
你知道规矩的。这绝对是一场惊人的划算买卖。惊人的划算买卖。你可以读到很多汤姆·霍兰德的内容，而且非常棒。所以去 UnHerd 订阅吧。你的生活会因此变得更加美好。现在，回到节目中。罗纳德，我们这里有一个问题，
a great question from Barry Grogan, one of our listeners, friend of the show. He says, does paganism in its popular understanding as exemplified by bearded men at Stonehenge bear any actual resemblance to the pre-Christian beliefs of Britain? Well, there are two different answers to that. First, is it invented in the 20th century? And the answer is yes and no, because there are streams of connection that come down directly from ancient to modern paganism. And they are created in the ancient world, they reflect the ancient world, and they connect straight to the modern. Like the custom of ceremonial ritual magic, invoking spirits using elaborate equipment and conjurations, like its downgraded but more useful folk equivalent of popular magic, simple spells and remedies used by cunning folk
一个来自我们的听众、节目老朋友巴里·格罗根（Barry Grogan）的绝妙问题。他说：“大众理解中的异教（以巨石阵里的络腮胡男子为代表）与英国的前基督教信仰之间，真的有任何实际的相似之处吗？”嗯，有两个不同的答案。首先，它是20世纪发明的吗？答案是：既是也不是。因为确实有一些联系的流脉直接从古代流传到现代异教。它们在古代世界创造，反映了古代世界，并直接连接到现代。比如仪式魔法的传统，使用精心准备的设备和咒语来召唤精灵；比如它被降级但更有用的民间对应物——大众魔法，即由“精明的人”
and wise folk, like seasonal customs, because there really are calendar customs in Britain, which do come down from the pagan ancient world. And they come down to the present. Customs, dances, rituals. And finally, I think most important, the unending love affair of Christian Europeans with the pagan ancient world, particularly the art and literature of Greece and Rome, but also Irish medieval, Norse medieval mythology reflecting paganism. The crucial difference between this and modern paganism is that all these streams are carried on by people who seem to be, to some degree or another, Christian, whereas in modern times all four have been recombined and pagan goddesses and
和“智慧之人”使用的简单咒语和疗法；比如季节习俗，因为英国确实存在一些日历习俗，它们确实是从古代异教世界流传下来的。它们一直流传至今。习俗、舞蹈、仪式。最后，我认为最重要的是，基督教欧洲人对古代异教世界永无止境的热爱，特别是希腊和罗马的艺术与文学，还有反映异教的中世纪爱尔兰、中世纪北欧神话。这与现代异教的关键区别在于，所有这些流脉都是由在某种程度上看似基督徒的人延续下来的，而在现代，这四者被重新组合，异教女神和
gods put back in to create a viable and, in modern terms, completely authentic pagan religion. But also to look at this question of revival, most great religious traditions have a point in their history at which they go back to their roots. So Protestant Christianity is based on jettisoning about a thousand years of medieval Christian tradition between to go back to the ancient world and recreate it. And recreation movements have happened in Islam, in Hinduism, in Buddhism over the millennia. So it's not unusual to find religious people reaching back over a long gap in order to remake something in the present. And as for the people in robes at Stonehenge, we actually know so little about prehistoric British religion, especially that of the Druids, the priests of the Iron Age, that it's really almost anybody's guess which is right and which is wrong. In other
神明被重新创造出一个可行的、用现代术语来说完全真实的异教。但同时也要看到复兴的问题，大多数伟大的宗教传统在其历史中都有一个回归根源的节点。因此，新教基督教的基础是抛弃大约一千年的中世纪基督教传统，回到古代世界并重塑它。几千年来，伊斯兰教、印度教和佛教中也发生过重塑运动。因此，宗教人士跨越长期的断层去重新创造现在的东西并不罕见。至于那些身穿长袍在巨石阵的人，我们对史前英国宗教，尤其是铁器时代德鲁伊神职人员的宗教，实际上知之甚少，以至于谁对谁错几乎全凭猜测。在其他
words, the modern Druids may have as good a chance of being authentic in their recreation of what ancient Druids did as anybody else. So it's a lot more of a free market than one might at first think. Yeah. You mentioned before the break that there was kind of radical left-wing and a radical right-wing enthusiasm for paganism. I suppose the most notorious right-wing enthusiast, certainly for the occult, and I don't know, maybe for paganism, would have been Himmler. What is the link between Nazism and paganism? Is that something that has deep roots, or is that kind of fabricated completely? It's neither fabricated nor deep-rooted. It's a very weak link. The idea of pagan revival is a language that's going around Europe in the early 20th century.
话说回来，现代德鲁伊在重塑古代德鲁伊的行为方面，可能和其他人有一样高的真实性概率。所以这比人们最初想象的要更像一个自由市场。是的。你在休息前提到，对异教有一种激进左翼和激进右翼的热情。我想最臭名昭著的右翼狂热分子，当然是对神秘学的狂热，我不知道，也许对异教的狂热，应该是希姆莱。纳粹主义和异教之间有什么联系？这是一种有着深厚根基的东西，还是完全虚构出来的？它既不是虚构的，也不是根深蒂固的。这是一种非常微弱的联系。异教复兴的想法是20世纪初在欧洲流传的一种语言。
And so it gets into some Nazis just as it gets into some of everybody, right or left. And the Nazis actually outlaw paganism, modern paganism in Germany, along with Freemasonry, occultism, and indeed naturism, anything which gets people together in private societies in which they might just discuss politics that they wiped out. Himmler is really the only one among the Nazi leadership with any interest in paganism. And as you'd expect, perhaps, it's an extremely batty, idiosyncratic, vamped-up vision of paganism, infused with colossally unrealistic ideas about nationalism. And there's no leakage from Himmler's idea of paganism to anybody else's, except maybe among people, tiny groups of people, who are conscious recreationist neo-Nazis at the present time.
因此它进入了一些纳粹分子心中，就像它进入了所有人的心中一样，无论是左翼还是右翼。纳粹实际上在德国取缔了异教、现代异教，以及共 Freemasonry、神秘主义，甚至自然主义，任何能让人们聚集在私人社团中讨论政治的事情都被他们消灭了。希姆莱实际上是纳粹领导层中唯一对异教感兴趣的人。正如你可能预料的那样，这是一个极其古怪、独断、拼凑出来的异教愿景，注入了对民族主义极其不切实际的想法。希姆莱的异教观念没有流传到其他任何人那里，除了当今有意识地重构新纳粹的极少数人之外。
You mentioned Freemasonry and naturism, and that brings us quite neatly to the man who, probably more than any other, is seen as the father of British paganism or of revived or reinvented British paganism. He's a man called gerald gardner now he's an absolutely fascinating man he uh a freemason a child of a colonial family brought up in salon self-taught uh a volunteer in all kinds of things archaeology archaeological enthusiast egyptology enthusiast um sunbathing enthusiast, a member of the local conservative association.
你提到了共济会和自然主义，这把我们很自然地引向了这样一个人：与其他人相比，他更被视为英国异教或复兴/重塑英国异教之父。他是一个叫杰拉德·加德纳的人，现在他是一个绝对迷人的人，他呃是一个共济会员，一个在锡兰长大的殖民地家庭的孩子，自学成才，各种事物的志愿者，考古爱好者，古埃及学爱好者，呃日光浴爱好者，当地保守党协会的成员。
So he is the man, isn't he? I mean, an extraordinary fellow. And would there be a sort of... So he's the father of Wicca. Would there be Wicca without him? Wicca, modern pagan witchcraft, would not really exist in its present form without Gerald Gardner. It would probably have existed in some form because of this immense popular belief, thanks to Margaret Murray and other writers, in pagan witchcraft as the basic religion of medieval early modern commoners. But what Gardner did was put a framework around it. He was definitely the publicist of Wicca, and he was definitely one of the creators of it whether he was the original one whether he was single-handed initially we don't know the evidence isn't there but without gerald gardner
所以他就是那个人，不是吗？我的意思是，一个非凡的家伙。那么会有一种……所以他是威卡教之父。如果没有他，会有威卡教吗？威卡教，现代异教巫术，如果没有杰拉德·加德纳，将不会以其现在的形式真正存在。由于玛格丽特·默里和其他作家的著作，人们对异教巫术作为中世纪早期现代平民基本宗教的巨大普遍信仰，它可能会以某种形式存在。但加德纳所做的是围绕它建立了一个框架。他绝对是威卡教的宣传者，他绝对是它的创造者之一，无论是最初的独创者还是单枪匹马，我们都不知道，证据并不充分，但如果没有杰拉德·加德纳
we would not have modern paganism in its actual form and he sets it up in a in a former i mean and this this sort of people who know nothing about this will be unsurprised, I suspect, to hear he sets it up in a former naturist resort, does he? Is that where the first coven is established? Well, we don't know where the first coven was established, but his original one was set up in an actual, a living, a thriving naturist resort, or to be exact, on a piece of land in the corner of it, which he owns directly. So you've described Wicca as the only fully formed religion which England can be said to
我们就不会有现在这种形式的现代异教，他在一个前——我的意思是，对这些一无所知的人听到这个会毫不惊讶，我猜——他把它建立在一个前自然主义度假村，是吗？第一个女巫团就是在那建立的吗？嗯，我们不知道第一个女巫团是在哪里建立的，但他的原初女巫团是在一个实际的、生机勃勃的、繁荣的自然主义度假村建立的，确切地说，是在它角落里的一块他直接拥有的土地上。所以你把威卡教描述为英格兰可以说给予世界的唯一完全形成的宗教。
have given the world. That may no longer be true as new religions are being born all the time. I'm perfectly happy to call it the first. I defend that remark against outraged adherents of almost every other religion by saying that until Wicca, Britain had produced extremely important variants of denominations of existing religions, such as Christianity. But Wicca was the very, very first religion that seems holy to have been born in England. And I stress England. I said there's a couple, well, maybe it isn't a paradox, but it's a religion that claims to be very ancient,
随着新宗教不断诞生，这可能不再是真的。我很高兴称它为第一个。我用这样的话来捍卫这一言论，以反驳几乎所有其他宗教愤怒的信徒：直到威卡教产生之前，英国产生的只是现有宗教（如基督教）极其重要的教派变体。但威卡教是似乎完全诞生于英格兰的第一个宗教。我强调英格兰。我说过有一对儿，好吧，也许这不是一个悖论，但这是一个声称非常古老的宗教，
that looks back to the pre-Christian world for its wellsprings. And yet simultaneously is kind of emerges in 1950s suburban England. Is that a tension that kind of has run throughout the decades that have followed Gardner? It's a simple yes. It's a very dynamic tension. And Gardner himself had it both ways, which is a large part of the reason of his success. On the one hand, he says that this religion is what's been around since the Stone Age and was persecuted heroically and horribly in the medieval early modern period. On the other hand, once you're initiated into it, you're perfectly entitled to make up new bits of it or even scrap old bits of it according to your taste so it's at once immemorial
它将目光投向基督教世界之前的源头。然而与此同时，它又某种程度上诞生于20世纪50年代的英国郊区。这种张力是否贯穿了加德纳之后的几十年？答案很简单：是的。这是一种非常动态的张力。加德纳本人两头兼顾，这也是他成功的大部分原因。一方面，他说这个宗教自石器时代以来就存在，在中世纪和近代早期曾遭受过英雄般和可怕的迫害。另一方面，一旦你加入其中，你完全有权根据自己的品味创造它的新部分，甚至废弃它的旧部分，所以它既是亘古不变的
and ultra modern which is the perfect package for a dynamic new religion and by and large i've seen you um in print rejecting the idea that it's people who are fleeing from the modern world because you pointed out that wicker adher adherents are sometimes, you know, computer engineers or scientists or something. Is there a particular, from the 1950s or 1940s onwards, is there a particular social type that's been drawn to it, do you think? Or is it completely sort of variegated? I'd love to get away with saying it's completely variegated and keep everybody happy, but it's not. It attracts a particular type of personality and a particular politico-social group. The particular type of personality is somebody who's highly literate, self-confident, eager for novelty and personal growth and self-exploration and doesn't feel trashed by life. That's a
又超级现代，这是充满活力的全新宗教的完美组合。大体上，我看到你……在印刷品中拒绝这种观点，即这是逃离现代世界的人，因为你指出威卡教信徒有时是（你知道的）计算机工程师或科学家之类的人。从20世纪50年代或40年代开始，有没有一种特定的社会类型被它吸引，你认为呢？还是它是完全多样的？我很乐意说它是完全多样的并让每个人都高兴，但事实并非如此。它吸引了特定类型的个性和特定的政治社会群体。特定类型的个性是那些高度自信、高度自我、渴望新奇、个人成长和自我探索并且不觉得自己被生活摧毁的人。这是一个
particular mindset. People with other mindsets are going to be attracted to other religions, but that's your classic pagan type, adventurous, self-confident, out to make something of themselves. And as for its socio-political appeal, overwhelmingly it's appealed to counter-cultural types people who are interested in radical cultural ideas it was a great thing among the hippie movement for example the 60s and 70s that gave it a quantum leap and it appeals to that sort of person today which is why the greatest weakness of modern paganism is that it has nobody from the elite anywhere openly a part of it. It doesn't have a single leading politician, leader of industry, pop star, high court judge. Has a pagan ever been on Thought for the Day?
特殊的心态。具有其他心态的人会被其他宗教吸引，但这就是你的经典异教徒类型，充满冒险精神、自信、渴望成就自我。至于其社会政治吸引力，它绝大多数吸引的是反文化类型的人，对激进文化理念感兴趣的人——例如，它是600年代和700年代嬉皮士运动中的一件大事，这使它有了一个质的飞跃，并且它今天仍然吸引着那种人，这就是为什么现代异教的最大弱点在于没有任何精英公开成为其中的一部分。它没有一个主要的政治家、行业领袖、流行歌星、高等法院法官。异教徒上过《今日思想》节目吗？
I just don't know i just don't know i mean there is another side to this that's being counter-cultural as a self-fulfilling prophecy if you seem to be espousing ideas that are against mainstream ideas then the mainstream is liable to squash you and certainly i i know from bitter experience that even to be known to be studying or writing about the history of modern paganism can get you a lot of flack, disdain, horror, discouragement, let alone somebody who's actually out as a practicing pagan. So if there were somebody in the upper ranks of society, the economy, the cultural world who was a believing pagan, they'd be very brave to admit it. And you have also, I mean, on that theme, you've also written fascinatingly about the challenges of being an academic, a historian, writing about beliefs and attitudes towards the supernatural that in a way modern academics have no way of fitting them in. There's no way to explore the possibility, for instance, that they might be true.
我只是不知道，我只是不知道，我的意思是，这还有另一面，那就是作为自我实现预言的反文化。如果你似乎在拥护违背主流思想的思想，那么主流就可能会压垮你。当然，我从惨痛的经验中知道，甚至让人知道你在研究或撰写现代异教历史，都会给你带来很多抨击、不屑、恐惧和沮丧，更不用说那些公开作为实践异教徒的人了。因此，如果社会、经济、文化领域高层中有人是信仰异教的信徒，他们承认这一点将需要极大的勇气。而且你还——我的意思是，关于这个主题，你也写过关于作为一名学术人员、历史学家所面临的挑战的迷人文章，撰写关于超自然现象的信念和态度的文章，现代学术界在某种程度上无法适应这些。例如，没有任何方法去探索它们可能是真的可能性。
Yeah, absolutely so. In an openly agnostic way, I leave it open as to whether deities and spirits actually exist, simply because I think it's the honest conclusion. I have encountered historically and in real life, huge numbers of people who claim to have met deities and encountered spirits. I never have. I have no evidence myself that they exist. And so because these are areas into which human beings ultimately can't go, there's no determinant, I leave them open. And that worries both believers and other religions and atheists alike when I do that. But I also get a double jeopardy in this kind of subject matter itself, in that those whom I might politely call pagan counter-revisionists, whom I'm tempted to call pagan fundamentalists, who really want to believe in the origin myths of modern paganism, the literal continuous survival of a religion that is theirs and like theirs tend to attack me savagely uh and people like me fortunately they almost always live in in different hemispheres from makes it a bit easier but uh really in the 2000s i i got a hate mail from somebody usually in america who's a pagan every single night i don't have my email box and there would be this heap of offal in the morning.
是的，完全如此。以一种公开不可知论的方式，我对神灵和灵魂是否真的存在持开放态度，纯粹是因为我认为这是最诚实的结论。我在历史和现实生活中遇到过大量声称见过神灵和遇到过灵魂的人。我从来没有。我自己没有证据证明它们存在。因此，由于这些是人类最终无法涉足的领域，没有决定性的结论，我将它们保持开放。当我这样做时，信徒、其他宗教以及无神论者都对此感到担忧。但我在这种题材本身中也遭到了双重打击，因为我可能会礼貌地称之为异教反修正主义者、我很想称之为异教原教旨主义者的人，他们真的想相信现代异教的起源神话、一个属于他们且像他们的宗教的字面连续生存，往往会野蛮地攻击我和像我这样的人。幸运的是，他们几乎总是生活在不同的半球，这让事情变得容易一些，但在2000年代，我真的经常在电子邮件信箱里收到来自美国的异教徒的恨信，每天晚上都有，早晨就会有这样一堆垃圾。
So you just learn to live with it. And this is because you were basically saying, because you dug into the history and you'd sort of say, some of these things are clearly invented or these are contingent and there's ambiguities and it's not as straightforward and it's not a religion that's been received all in one go kind of thing. Yeah, but there's also a big national difference. And that is that by the time that I was persuaded to write about this,
所以你只需要学会忍受它。这是因为你基本上是在说，因为你深入研究了历史，你会说，其中一些事情显然是凭空捏造的，或者是偶然的，其中存在模棱两可，事情并非那么简单，它不是一次性接收的宗教，诸如此类。是的，但这里也有很大的国别差异。那就是，当我被劝说写这本书的时候，
it was the 1990s, late 1980s, 90s, by which time the leaders of British paganism had already read the latest academic research and lost faith in their own origin myth. So there was now a vacuum where they didn't know where they'd come from. And I agreed to go into that vacuum and try and find the story, the history, or at least one that I could find in it, and provide them with a homeland from which they'd come and help an identity, which is why I was so supported and helped by British pagans and treated so well by them. But across the Atlantic, and especially in the United States, but also Canada, Australia, New Zealand, there are lots of people who have only just been converted
已经是20世纪90年代，80年代末、90年代了，当时英国异教的领导人已经阅读了最新的学术研究，并对他们自己的起源神话失去了信心。因此，现在出现了一个真空，他们不知道自己来自何方。我同意进入这个真空并试图寻找故事、历史，或者至少能在其中找到一个，并为他们提供一个他们赖以发源的家园，帮助他们建立认同，这就是为什么我得到了英国异教徒的大力支持和帮助，并受到他们如此好的对待。但在大西洋彼岸，特别是在美国，还有加拿大、澳大利亚、新西兰，有很多人刚刚被
to paganism by people who believed thoroughly in the origin myths. And so just after their conversions, they found themselves learning about my work and thought that I was attacking the very thing to which they'd just been converted. I was a religious enemy and, of course, blew up. But I must say none of the flak that I got from pagans, especially pagans abroad, really ranked for unpleasantness with just the ongoing grinding hostility of ordinary British people who were scandalised that somebody like me should take off time to write about this kind of stuff at all. And yet, I mean, I think you can convincingly argue that this is a kind of quite an important strain of modern British religious identity. And do you think that you see its influence in things that are much more mainstream?
对起源神话深信不疑的人转化为了异教徒。因此，就在他们皈依后不久，他们发现自己了解到了我的工作，并认为我是在攻击他们刚刚皈依的东西。我是宗教敌人，当然就爆发了。但我必须说，我从异教徒（尤其是外国异教徒）那里受到的所有抨击，在令人不快方面，根本无法与普通英国人持续不断、折磨人的敌意相比，他们对像我这样的人竟然花时间去写这种东西感到震惊。然而，我的意思是，我认为你可以令人信服地论证，这是现代英国宗教认同中一个相当重要的支流。你是否认为你在更主流的事物中看到了它的影响？
So I'm thinking of, say, Glastonbury Festival, the Stonehenge Festival before it got cancelled, and perhaps in the environmental movement at the moment, that pagan ideas, if not exactly inspiring them, are definitely a part of the mix. Yes, they're definitely part of the mix for anything that's counter-cultural in its way. Stonehenge Festival was the shop window of the counter-culture of the time. That's why it got banned. And Glastonbury Festival has really carried on that tradition. And indeed, the layout of the festival site, especially its stern circle, is the work of pagans. But it also gives a kind of...
因此我想到的是，比方说，格拉斯顿伯里音乐节，在被取消之前的巨石阵音乐节，也许还有目前的环保运动，异教思想即使没有直接激发它们，也绝对是其中的一部分。是的，它们绝对是任何以自己的方式反文化的活动的一部分。巨石阵音乐节是当时反文化的橱窗。这就是它被禁的原因。格拉斯顿伯里音乐节确实延续了这一传统。事实上，音乐节场地的布局，尤其是它的石圈，就是异教徒的作品。但这同时也赋予了一种……
The pyramid stage? Is that... Vaguely. I mean, pyramids were built by pagans in ancient Egypt. But the idea that there is something inherently sacred in the structure of the pyramid is a kind of non-pagan American New Age idea. It's a different strand of esotericism. But also you get what I might call pagan leakage into mainstream culture. You find pagan ideas turning up beautifully satirized along with everything else in the best-selling novels of Terry Pratchett, who in the 90s was the best-selling British author of all. You get pagan motifs in the songs of the pretenders of Prissy Hynde in the 80s and Tori Amos in the 90s. So you do get a kind of spillover. In many ways, that's part of the normalisation of paganism as a single strand in a multi-faith society,
金字塔舞台？那是……隐约是。我的意思是，金字塔是由古埃及的异教徒建造的。但认为金字塔的结构中存在某种固有的神圣性的想法，是一种非异教的美国新时代思想。这是深奥秘术的不同支流。但你也会发现我可能称之为异教向主流文化的渗透。你会发现异教思想与其它所有内容一起，在特里·普拉切特（Terry Pratchett）的畅销小说中得到了精彩的讽刺，普拉切特在90年代是英国最畅销的作家。你在80年代的Pretenders（由Chrissie Hynde演唱）和90年代的Tori Amos的歌曲中也能找到异教的主题。所以你确实会得到一种溢出效应。在很多方面，这是异教作为多元信仰社会中单一支流实现正常化的一部分，
which I think is its destiny. Can I ask a very boring, mundane question about paganism and Wicca? Am I right in thinking that most Wiccans believe in, effectively, it's a dualistic religion, so a mother goddess and a male horned god. And if that is right, given that paganism is countercultural, does that mean that the current sort of, all the debates about gender politics and so on, have they had an effect on what British Wiccans believe?
我认为这是它的宿命。我能问一个关于异教和威卡教的非常无聊、世俗的问题吗？我这样想对吗：大多数威卡教徒实际上相信它是一个二元论宗教，即一个大地女神和一个男性有角神。如果这是真的，鉴于异教是反文化的，这是否意味着当前关于性别政治等的各种辩论，对英国威卡教徒的信仰产生了影响？
They've had an enormous effect and vice versa. The deities of paganism are deities of the natural world. Every night on ITN News, we hear more about the fact the natural world seems apparently heading for shipwreck, for extermination. So these are big topical issues. The horned god, incidentally, is simply Pan, although nowadays often under other names. The three great modern ingredients which give paganism its life force are one, feminism, which is hugely important because ancient paganism did have goddesses as well as gods or instead of them,
它们产生了巨大的影响，反之亦然。异教的神灵是自然界的神灵。每天晚上在ITN新闻上，我们都会听到更多关于自然界似乎正走向毁灭、灭绝的信息。所以这些都是重大的热门话题。顺便说一句，有角神其实就是潘神，尽管现在经常用其他名字。赋予异教生命力的三个伟大的现代因素是：第一，女权主义，这极其重要，因为古代异教既有女神也有男神，或者以女神代男神，
and priestesses instead of or as well as priests, and so does modern paganism. There's a sense of an imminent divinity in nature, a beauty and a holiness in nature, which has obvious relevance to the present ecological crisis. And there's the idea in ancient paganism that deities don't give laws to humans, that in Europe they didn't create them. And they're actually not terribly interested in them. I lost the time. You have to get their attention. And that fits in very well with a modern world of personal growth, self-expression and freedom of choice based, and this is awfully important to modern pagans, on responsible social attitudes. In other words, to fulfil yourself and do what you like, but avoid doing harm to anything else, including the planet and anybody else in the process.
而且有女祭司代替或伴随男祭司，现代异教也是如此。人们感觉到自然中有一种内在的神性，自然中存在美和神圣，这与当前的生态危机具有明显的关联。古代异教中还有这样一种观点：神灵不向人类颁布法律，他们在欧洲也没有创造人类。而且他们实际上对人类并不十分感兴趣。我忘了时间。你必须引起他们的注意。这非常契合现代个人成长、自我表达和基于个人选择自由的世界，而这对现代异教徒来说极其重要，其基础是负责任的社会态度。换句话说，充实自我，做自己喜欢的事，但在过程中避免对任何其他事物（包括地球和他人）造成伤害。
I reckon that we have, well, I mean, we've reached the 21st century. Ronald, if you are up for it, I think there's so much more to talk about that perhaps we could do another episode. And in that we could go back through time, we could go back through the Middle Ages, we could go back, well, ultimately, perhaps to the Paleolithic and explore what can be known of ancient paganism. Yeah, no, you're very welcome we will uh we will rejoin tomorrow uh and hopefully uh we will we will have you back then bye-bye goodbye thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community,
我想我们已经——我的意思是，我们已经进入了21世纪。罗纳德，如果你愿意的话，我认为还有很多事情可以谈，也许我们可以录制另一期节目。在节目中我们可以穿越回过去，我们可以穿越回中世纪，我们可以穿越回——最终，也许到旧石器时代，并探索人们对古代异教的了解。好的，不，非常欢迎，我们将在明天再次会面，希望我们到时能请你回来，拜拜，再见，谢谢收听《历史的其余部分》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听加长节目、提前点播、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，
please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。